now Chris also has another connection to
music and you guys may not get this okay
but you would pretty get sent this a lot
it's you know the way on on websites and
things you get those things at the
bottom work order you know 20 child
actors you won't believe what they look
like now yeah so this this is one called
20 photos that will stop you it's a list
of celebs ruined by drugs okay celebs
ruined by drugs this is number 12
he's a celebrity ah that Shin gon used
to be in a band called The Pogues he's
fantastic kind of punk what what's
frustrating about the photo is I can see
it
we're not way off
I'm Saturday morning I get centered a
lot and I mean he's ephant I met him
once randomly at like a Irish awards
thing and he is he's a great kind of
supposed to call it like punked rod is
that what you'd call it but fantastic
singer and I met him at like an Irish
award thing and he was getting like a
Lifetime Achievement I was getting some
nonsense for comedy and at some stage
his manager came over and said you know
Shane would love to meet you and he'd be
a big hero of mine and she would love to
meet you he's a big fan so I was like
great and it was like it was a Black Tie
thing but it was like during the summer
so I take my jacket off and I went over
and I sat with him and I was babbling on
he wasn't making a lot of conversation
but I was like I'm talking to Shane
MacGowan this is a big moment and then
eventually he said I'll just have a
vodka Tyco I realized he thought I was a
waiter
you